With just a fraction of
humanitarian aid reaching those
whose lives depended on.
>> Fresh snow blanketed the
hills of the province in
central Afghanistan.
Creating the illusion of a
winter wonderland.
But, for those who live here,
there is no wonder.
Let alone a glimmer of hope.
Simply staying alive is a
deadly struggle.
For this family, their young
son lost that battle.
Now, they huddle around his
hillside grave, offering
prayers to six year old what
he'd who, just days ago, froze
to death.
>> I miss my brother, and that
is why I came to visit him at
the graveyard he says.
>> Abdul moved his family to
the township in core --
looking for work as a labor.
Taliban-controlled Afghanistan,
he was unable to make ends
meet.
[Speaking non-english]
I had nothing to bring to keep
the house warm, he explains, I
checked on the children during
the night and their bodies were
numb.
I realized my son had died.
>> This is a photo of him last
year, he says.
And this is his dead body.
And president sly brutal winter
has claimed countless Afghan
lives this year.
But so too has extreme poverty.
This has been exacerbated by
the repercussions of the
Taliban governments dystopian
gender policies.
♪ ♪ ♪
and the response by the
international communities.
Almost a year ago, the Taliban
banned female secondary school
students from attending school,
that has morphed into a
nationwide event on all female
education.
But, it was the Taliban's
decision in December, banning
women from working for non
governmental organizations that
forced humanitarian aid groups
to abruptly halt or suspend
operations.
>> There is 28 million Afghans
in desperate need at the
moment.
28 million.
And we're not even reaching a
fraction of those.
>> The Norwegian refugee
council says, they normally
helped 700,000 Afghans each
year's.
But the operation has been
drastically --
the secretary general, recently
traveled to kabul, pleading the
collab and to allow female aid
workers to return to work.
>> It is at its worst hour.
It's never been as bad as it is
now.
>> 35-year-old --
wipes away her tears as she
grieves for her husband who
perished from the cold also in
--
province, father and
breadwinner for their eight
children, the youngest of just
two.
Now, she's wondering how to
keep her family alive.
[Speaking non-english]
>> I have no education, she
says.
My children need food, what
should I do?
Three of her children are girls,
including 12-year-old --
who knows all too well what
happens to poor young Afghan
girls who reach puberty.
[Speaking non-english]
>> I am worried that if we
don't have food, my brothers
will be forced to sell or marry
me under pressure, she says.
I don't want to get married.
I'm a kid.
I don't want a husband.
U.S. Charity too young to web
said they've been able to
provide emergency aid for the
family and many others.
But founder, Stephanie Sinclair,
says the avalanche of need is
overwhelming.
And they're unable to help
everyone.
>> To me, it's unconscionable
that the international
community is not paying more
attention to what's happening
to women and girls in
Afghanistan.
It is simply, just inexcusable
that we are not doing
everything in our power to try
to change the course of what's
happening there.
We have to do better.
>> And with the U.N. Predicting
two thirds of the population